the only remaining abortion clinic in
Missouri says it won't comply with a
reinterpreted state regulation to give
women a pelvic exam at least 72 hours
before an abortion doctors call the
exams medically unnecessary critics say
it's an attempt to discourage women from
going through with abortions CBS News
broke this story and mega Oliver is
outside Planned Parenthood in st. Louis
Meghan could this result in the clinic
being shut down by tomorrow Anthony that
remains to be seen we obtained a copy of
the state's inspection report that's
more than 60 pages long Planned
Parenthood will filed their response
today the medical director here told me
that requiring a woman to undergo an
additional procedure that he believes to
be unethical was the last straw how hard
was it for you to make this decision to
have an abortion this is most definitely
one of the hardest decisions to make
this woman who doesn't want to be
identified for her own safety says she
can't support a child and her misery has
only been extended by the additional
pelvic exams she had to get days before
her abortion I feel that the pelvic exam
is just another way for them to tell you
of a decision that you already know you
want to make the Planned Parenthood
clinic is at the center of a national
abortion debate Missouri has some of the
strictest state regulations on abortions
and a recent inspection reportedly cited
the clinic for 30 deficiencies David
Eisenberg is the medical director it is
exhausting he says in May the state
reinterpreted an existing regulation
requiring his staff to perform an
additional pelvic exam I have new
evidence to say that a hundred percent
of the patients who I've taken care of
who've undergone this inappropriate
medically unnecessary and unethical
pelvic exam have been harmed by that the
clinic plans to file a letter in court
today stating that unless medically
indicated they will no longer require
patients to undergo a pelvic exam at
least 72 hours before an abortion I'm no
longer willing to practice medicine that
way even if it means your clinic gets
shut down I really hope that we get to
continue to provide that
quality patient-centered care for years
to come the decision is now rests with a
judge the Missouri Department of Health
and Senior Services didn't respond to
our request for comment it's director
previously defended pelvic exam
requirements for abortions is very much
a part of standard care saying the
department is trying to ensure the
safety of women but the American College
of Obstetricians and Gynaecologists says
routine multiple pelvic exams for women
seeking abortion care are unwarranted
invasive and not supported by evidence
they're gonna have an exam done when
it's medically appropriate but not at
any other time because to do so in my
opinion is just assault this comes at a
delicate time for this Planned
Parenthood clinic which has gone to
court over the state's refusal to renew
its license to perform abortions they
could rule on that as early as tomorrow
Gail a lot of people are watching thank
you very much Meg we remember when dr.
Lena Wynn was here who's now the head of
Planned Parenthood a lot is at stake and
she makes a very important case that you
know Planned Parenthood is so much more
than just abortions
yes it's very small part of what they
have I think people forget it seems like
the days are just getting along and
going along they're over there they're
inviting a challenge yes they were